hi I'm Andy and I work at Shopify we're
an e-commerce platform and today I'm
going to be giving you a whirlwind
introduction to typescript so first of
Reif disclaimer most of the stuff I'm
going to talk about today is typescript
specific but typescript is not the only
way to bring types into your javascript
there's a lot of other really good
options I actually first started with
flow and then we switched to typescript
at work and so that's what I do most of
my time but reason or flow or typescript
they're all great okay so first I want
to give you a little bit of why to use
types this is probably the most
important part and then we'll dive into
some typescript syntax to hopefully make
it a little less scary to get started so
I really want to talk about two main
reasons that you would want to use types
in your project the first one is that if
you're working on a large application as
that application grows it's impossible
to keep in your own mind everything
that's happening so if you're working on
a small library like maybe the overhead
of types is a little bit overkill but if
you're working on a really big
application eventually it's gonna get to
the point where you can't keep track of
all the changes that are happening to
functions or other interfaces in your
application but the compiler can keep
track of that so it's like having this
like super powered buddy on your team
who's gonna keep track of everything
that's happening the second thing is
that it's really hard to keep
documentation up to date whether it be
comments in your code or whether it be a
readme or whatever else the nice thing
about types is that they're kind they
make your code a little more self
documenting and since the compiler is
going to be enforcing those types it's a
lot harder to get them out of date it's
definitely possible and it's definitely
easy to do things that still make it
hard to understand but it's a little bit
of a help to make your code easier to
jump into all right so basic types we're
gonna start going pretty fast through
typescript syntax here just to kind of
do an overview so here is like sort of a
hello world of some very primitive types
and typescript you can see that it looks
a lot like normal Travis
script but you have a colon and then the
name of a type which is how you're gonna
annotate your variables now that
actually isn't necessary a lot of the
time I would say that I more often than
not don't have to add explicit
annotations to my code because
typescript is very good at inferring
what I what I mean you can also see here
this is where the benefit starts coming
in so this screenshot is from Visual
Studio code but it's really just a
reflection of the error that the
compiler is outputting so you're not
tied to using vs code with typescript
but you can see it has a red squiggly
under this index of call because the
boolean doesn't have a method called
index of all right so arrays this is a
little more complicated but looks much
the same so you have an annotation and
you just put square brackets after 8 to
say that it's an array so you can see
here I have this array of foods and if I
initialize it to these strings it's
happy if I push in a new string it's
still happy but if I were to try to
initialize it to an array of numbers or
if I were to push in a boolean it's
going to complain at me and I would have
to fix that
functions so this is where things get
really exciting so your functions you're
gonna be importing them all over the
place in your application before those
were like pretty contrived examples
because like you can look at your
variables three or four lines above or
you know even in the same file but a
function this is where you're gonna be
able to catch things across your whole
application as you import things so you
can see here that I typed my parameter
with that same annotation there's
another annotation after the arguments
list which is the return type and then
we just write normal JavaScript on the
inside so if I pass a trace car it's
going to be happy but if I pass it a
boolean then it's going to complain
again typescript is pretty smart at
inferring what my variables are going to
be and what my return types are so we
can actually omit that return type if
you don't want to do so much typing all
right unions this is again a little bit
more of an advanced feature so you can
think about a union like an or this is
something that I use all the time so
here like I want to say that a vegetable
can be a broccoli or a carrot I say that
fruit can be any of these fruits and
then I can also use unions with types so
I can say that an ingredient
for this restaurant is going to be
either a vegetable or a fruit and it can
be any of those values so then if I'm
making a recipe for juice and I give it
broccoli and watermelon it's happy but
if I try to make this sludge drink out
of bread and bacon it's going to be very
unhappy because that's neither a
vegetable nor a fruit
all right interfaces this is going to be
our last type and then we'll go through
a short little example
so interfaces this is how you type
objects so this looks a lot like playing
object notation you have a colon and
then instead of the value you put your
type name you also can use all of these
other features inside of your interfaces
so here we have a union between a bunch
of animals you have your favorite animal
you can make it optional by allowing
nulls and then type script will help you
check null before you try to access
those values or anything like that all
right
so most of my day I spend writing react
and that is like where typescript really
shines for me I like it pretty well when
I'm writing playing typescript but for
react components I think it's the bee's
knees so I'm here we have a really
simple example if you used the prop
types package this probably looks very
familiar to you because in prop types
you also have to like declare your props
the nice thing about this is you get a
little more help from the compiler and
it happens at compile time instead of at
runtime the other nice thing is that you
don't have to include the prop types
package all of this gets stripped out at
compile time and then you ship a smaller
bundle a little bit so just to walk
through this we have our props we're
gonna have one prop called size that
accepts either small medium or large and
then we just pass it into our component
as usual and you can see here that
inside my component I have very little
typescript specific syntax it really
looks pretty much like normal JavaScript
and then this is what it looks like to
use that so I import my icon component
and if I don't give it any props
typescript is going to complain to me
because I told it that I was expecting
some props here if I give it size it can
suggest to me what those props should be
so this is really nice when you're like
using a design system inside your
company
you can know exactly what the values are
supposed to be again this is the vs code
interface but when you run the
typescript compiler it gives you this
exact same suggestion where it'll list
what it's expecting and if I give it
something that it's expecting it will be
happy you know compile my code and I can
run it so I hope that has made
typescript a little less mysterious you
can find me at AS Moakler thank you very
much
[Applause]